sloppy you just recently moved to Los
Angeles after living in New York for a
bazillion year for 12 years and it's
like all my New York friends were like
doesn't LA suck and I'm like what's the
best it's so nice New York is a great
place to live if you want to get better
at comedy but la is a great place to
live if you want to get worse at
comedies
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys can we just get back to talking
about dicks and let me get through this
live read Zulily calm is where you need
to go Zulily calm slash nikki for an
extra 20% off already huge savings
Zulily calm speaking of huge let's talk
about dicks cars here you've already
heard him already surrounded by four men
this feels like a night out for you so
exciting for me I love I love this this
crew in here Jimmy Carr is here tickets
are on sale now for his new Lily duck
Zulily cool them car.com go see him on
tour funny before anyone's thinking
about buying it you know that you are
Jimmy how you doing this morning with
drunk last night I found a bar in New
York what my friend found a bar where
you can still smoke
what there's a bar New York Oh Hudson in
books let me look it up baby are they
not gonna be excited that your licenses
in New York four bars that were cigar
bars originally and they couldn't take
the licenses away when they changed the
law and made a very small little places
yeah but it is alarmingly fun it's
almost like owning a time machine I
walked in there like whatever it was it
was late or on the morning plane like
wow that's so quaint and new it's like
that's every bar in Oklahoma it's middle
America cosplay can you still smoke in
Oklahoma there's there's definitely
certain states where there's there's an
indoor smoking right where they'll just
eat the fines because people won't go to
their bar
if they can't smoke like in Indiana and
I don't believe you because you have
wolves on your last night yeah I went to
a bar with like late night late now I've
got a friend that was filming a thing I
was filming things so we went three miss
friend
Russell Crowe I feeling it was something
like that yeah it was fun though cool so
we're doing some some some pretty good
whiskey and tequila and
I can't believe I'm here I imagine you
only smoke out of a pipe oh yeah chimney
sweep you what you were out until how
late four in the morning three there
were open till three it was oh my god
like I like I like no I drink at the end
I don't drink much but I like I'm
wondering what does that mean you don't
drink much your your teetotal now right
mm-hmm
I was I would I gave up drinking for
about 12 or 13 years shut honest
actually when I started doing comedy I
saw I'd used to drink at college quite a
lot and that was drinking afterwards but
I wasn't happy I think drinking when
you're not happy is the worst and then I
just kind of I started doing comedy when
I just really want to do this and then I
just and I kind of thought I'd come to a
lot was about 26 when I started doing
comedy I I went oh I'd better really
focus on this I better and it was enough
fun that I didn't need anything else
comedy started not being fun anymore
I'll be okay I love that I'm coming up
on seven years December ninth of not
drinking alcohol so what was the what
was the thing what was the what was the
low point I felt the same way I was like
I wasn't happy I saw everyone's careers
that I wanted around me who were
successful people in comedy and I
realized oh they all don't have a
drinking problem either they don't drink
because they did have a problem or they
just don't drink that much and it's not
something that interferes with their
life every single night and so I can
every single night kind of yeah
cuz I could like I'd at least have a
couple drinks cuz you just can and I was
out every night and it's a weird thing
is one lie took me years they've kind of
like sort of when I started drinking
again you kind of go to a comedy club
into a set and then you you kind of
never have to buy another drink you
never there's a weird thing with no
money changing hands and there's
something about me going this is good
isn't it it's awesome
it's think of all the money you lost not
getting free drinks yeah yeah if you
don't drink they should just hand you
money like extra money every time you go
to the bar they detain you every couple
of the hami $7.00 after not when you
aren't drinking as a single woman and
guys are like can I buy you a drink I'm
always like no but you can like give me
give me like a
Starbucks gift card just like $7 is what
that would get me two coffees that I
would really enjoy down the road because
after a couple of drinks you can sleep
with a guy buddy who if he gives you $14
like a budget who are laser budget who
that could be the new special title I'm
working some thank you um so yeah it was
just I got to that point but let me ask
you what was the point where you go I'm
gonna have that first drink after 13 12
13 years built a house I built a house
and in London where I live and got a
house and we put a bar in it and so I
had a bar and I thought this is mental
I'm gonna have a drink and I kind of had
a thing where like the last couple years
I'm not drinking I would have like a I'd
have a Guinness at Christmas like at the
end of there like last gig I'd have like
a Guinness so quite liked it quite like
just having like one drink kind of
slightly fetishistic ly like not getting
drunk but just having one drink is like
a lovely edging my story but I'm
starting to have kind of I'm starting
out while I'm a very wealthy man he
wealthy um I'm starting to have I'm
starting to experiment with drugs now
yeah I like in my mid 40s I've started
to go oh actually I'm terrible at
relaxing
I've got no capacity to sit home and do
nothing and so I'm just starting to kind
of use marijuana now for the first time
I love it it's great it's a it's a very
interesting thing if you've never done
drugs always being sort quite an t
edibles do you edibles yeah I can't
really smoke I'm not yeah I did I feel
like I'm I feel like I'm in an Oscar
Wilde play yeah I feel like there's
something about me with the cigarette
hello Lyle fancy cool you need to get
laid that's a red flag when did you last
when did you last get get stuffed what
did you ask it's get stuffed with Nikki
Glaser is another great title for a show
I love to get come today it was we got a
finale for the show fellas it was what
morning it was Wednesday night for us
we're just gonna watch you trouble out
week ago one week ago one week ago one
week ago okay yeah I think is that when
I went to LA I don't even remember yeah
no Tuesday night it was Tuesday night a
Tuesday night yes it was a Tuesday night
well we all know the best sex is Tuesday
night now and how are the tacos did it
sit well do you have the tacos first the
Taco Tuesday extra can do just because
you thought it's Tuesday there's so many
things you're hitting on that I want to
like talk about yeah um it was a I had
gotten into town really late at night
and I just climbed into bed and we just
banged it out real quick it was just a
quick one and done I didn't even think I
was really gonna I was like not even in
the mood really and then it was one of
those ones that I was like I didn't know
I was in the mall I so much I think if a
guy's not on the mood that's a problem
if you're I believe I believe thumbing
in a softie is the expression if you're
if it's like trying to play pool with a
bit of rope if you're picking a lock
with a marshmallow that's an issue but
if the lady's not in the mood you can
just use I believe they call it
Australian charmed and they or saliva
yeah Australian child but that thing is
I I wasn't if I thought going into it I
because I hadn't seen this guy in a
while and I was like I'm really really
tired and like not into it and I never
get the same driver twice I'm amazed the
fact you're having to think about it I
was just thinking have I ever had sex
with someone who has driven for uber I
think you you would think of me in a
different way you know what that is
that's the sixth star oh she gave me the
sixth star yeah so it just it was one of
those I laid it I told him afterwards I
was like it's I did
know how much I need it it was like he
found a pressure point and just like dug
into it with his elbow like it's one of
those massages that was like wow Jesus
Christ like I didn't know that I it hurt
like it hurt good I don't know what I'm
trying to say here this is I think she's
trying to write a Madonna song from the
80s I think she's trying to rewrite like
a virgin like I was overly sensitive to
it where I was just like whoa I didn't
see that coming and I was just like it
was so it was so quick like I didn't see
it coming
I didn't see how much comes in so I
didn't see exactly had a cervical camera
so she could watch it it's we're not
doing coming in because I'm not on the
pill so it's always got to be out and
it's so unsatisfying we were talking
about that before he's pulled it out
yeah sorry
you're having you having unprotected sex
yep and he's just pulling out yep
because you're on the pill oh you know
like have you ever seen the teenage mom
show
do not take any sexual advice from this
lady we use the port method only four
years now and we come he's real I know
but I probably not I'm probably barren
is what my this is what I'm thinking cuz
I've never had a scared never anything
like I'm not I've never been pregnant
and I've been like having risky so what
let me just let me say it let me let me
just take a look yeah I've just I've
never been pregnant I've never I've had
things where I thought I was pregnant
but I've always just known like you're
not pregnant but you're just late
because you've been eating weird or
whatever so I think you should stop
family then I'm gonna go there I mean I
think you should start family or right
now I think you know aunt Rae
I would be a great mom oh oh so I was
gonna I didn't think so but no I'm just
I think you're running out things to
talk about in your comedy specials I
think you should have a family you can't
be you think you'd be a great mom yeah I
think I know someone who's gonna start
drinking again mommy needs a live-in er
get mummys special juice your mummys
special juice that's cool
ooba-dooba drive is cute tell him I like
him Jimmy when you started drinking
again how quickly did it get did it it's
you've had to have some nights where
you're like oh god what did I do all
those things that I've quit drinking
because I hate those nights I hate
nights where I've blacked out where I
don't I can't really piece it together
I've sent text I don't want I've written
tweets I don't care for and I just have
that anxiety the next the hangovers
terrible is the hangover I do
occasionally get the beer fear like a
tional II get the kind of thing the next
morning going oh man I'm the worst yeah
yeah but I tend to just get that I get
that a lot from travel I get that more
from travelling than I do from drinking
it's actually the the its exacerbated
maybe slightly by drink but actually I
just get the fear sometimes one I've
been traveling I've done about 40
countries this year and I find it if I
get my circadian rhythms out I get
depressed yeah that's what and the
drinking is like you maybe have a drink
take the edge off drink it to sleep and
then that's that's kind of more of a
thing rather than there cuz you still
get the everyone hates me thing now I
imagine have you listened back to the
show sometimes get that thing and I
think it's unrelated to drinking I think
that hangover thing of like I don't mind
having a hangover and feeling a bit
dehydrated what about not not a biggie
I'll deal with that but that kind of
depression the next day thinking oh my
god the anxiety thing yeah is I suffer
more than anxiety now than I ever have
and I think it's I think it's kind of
travel mites I think it's I think that's
why I'm kind of interested in marijuana
for that kind of deeper sleep yeah ready
to get hot no what you didn't get hired
REM sleep yeah but you don't get I took
I took the ten milligrams last night and
woke up just glued to the bed I was like
I slept eight hours but it felt like I
can't smoke before I go to bed because
the smoking high only lasts for three or
four hours and I wake up like in the
middle of the night Adamo keeps me
asleep the whole night but then it's not
good right I'm bad at sleeping that's
another reason I can tonin the best yeah
two milligrams a day every day it's like
it's it's really cool my girlfriend was
9 to 10 no my girl phone was doing like
milligrams at a time there were 10
milligram pills and she'd just go home
and she learned apparently there is a
curve and effectiveness curve that she
was overshooting by a mile so now she's
back down to like less than 10 yeah this
year where I flew to Australia twice in
January which is from London Wow
so got there and went right sleep I'll
take some valium so I'll give him some
valium took some valium and then I
basically had nothing left in my system
I didn't realize it strips all the
serotonin from you so took all this
stuff on the jetlag as well and was kind
of wandering around Australia going
I think bleak which way does London go
to Australia where's the it's direct
does it go over one of the poles or
something no no you you there is a one
direct flight into Perth but then the
downside is you arrive the yeah it's
kind of a no you fly maybe Hong Kong or
Singapore on the way okay but I think
you're right like all these things we
attribute to that's why I feel bad it's
really the drinking's messing up your
sleep and the sleep is what's really
causing you to be the lack of sleep or
the lack of the circadian rhythms being
all mess it's an interesting things with
like something like a a where people
deal with the drinking problem rather
than what's causing them to drink like
actually that you know good therapy and
I think a lot of this stuff with like
you know DMT and people doing ayahuasca
or whatever to kind of push through
whatever that thing is
that's mate you know and there's two
very different types of drinking there's
problem drinking and there's just hey
listen I went out for a drink with some
friends and we had a lot of fun it was
great yeah you're absolutely right i
mean people drinked because they're sad
and they don't want they want to numb
out i mean that's that's when you have a
drinking problem and that's that's the
same way like i eat sometimes like last
night i just got home and i was like i'm
feeling things i don't want to feel and
I'm just gonna stuff my face until I
feel sick and it's I'm doing the same
thing that I used to do with drinking
and part
me is like what you go to food I eat
really healthy stuff because I just like
want to eat everything and eat as I want
an excuse to be able to eat forever and
ever and ever and so I'll just eat like
veggies and hummus she's vegan and so
I'll just uh have you bent about the
butcher's daughter no a couple of
locations what is that are you making
yeah it's it's the way to be for sure
but it's yeah I binge on like really
healthy stuff but I will make myself
sick with healthy people go all you eat
salads I'm like you don't understand the
amounts I can put away and when I'm
going on like at an emotional binge I
feel like I'm talking to a crazy person
now the idea that you're going you're
binging on salad that's not a thing
that's not comfort eating it's really
yes I love salad I crave it I'm like I
love healthy foods and I eat disgusting
amounts of them where you'd be I'll eat
like I literally eat this is no reason
for seating you can eat for hours hours
whereas someone who's eating a cake can
only eat that cake for 15 minutes
however long it takes you to stuff a
cake in your face I get I can have the
same amount of calories that that cake
is over hours and I can eat the whole
time because then I prolong it's like
it's like I used to drink I used to
drink vodka sodas and I would do a
little bit of vodka a ton of soda so I
could just chug and chug and consume
volume without having the without
blacking out too fast you need vodka I
think this people fools all of this
relates to the size of her father's
penis is my choice it's all about oh my
god the idea of your bender being that
like most people go on a bender and they
wake up with like a stomach ache for all
the sugar bloated from the salt and you
wake up the next day and take the most
perfect
[Music]
[Laughter]
I do I have a hundred percent I have a
binge eating disorder like 100% but no
but it would never ring any alarms
because I binge eat healthy food so no
one's everyone's always like Oh Nicky
and all of our salads and it's like I'm
crying for help but it was suppressing
last night I was suppressing the fact
that the guy I'm seeing hasn't been as
as communicative with me as I want him
to be
I was suppressing that I performed a
song last night and I didn't nail it the
way I wanted it to
I was suppressing the fact that I made
you performed a song yeah goddamn Comedy
Jam Oh blank space Taylor Swift Taylor
Swift yeah it was we did her like a rock
version of it it's awesome it was
awesome it was really fun I mean the
fact that I wasn't gonna get enough
sleep cuz I wanted to eat a lot and I
will then if I went home and went to eat
a lot I still gotta be up for radio so I
was kind of stressed about not getting
enough sleep and then today I have like
a meeting after this and then I have
another thing later and I have to go to
Mike Birbiglia show tonight which I'm
very excited about but I'm also like
it's just another thing I have to dress
up for and like look good and then I'm
going to commies laughter I'm
suppressing all of the thing you have to
dress up for Mike Birbiglia not even
dressing up for married man with a child
I'm not dressing up so Mike Birbiglia is
like wow Nikki looks like it's like I'm
gonna take a picture and post on
Instagram because that's why he's giving
away free tickets all his friends anyway
so that we all promote it and so I can
talk about how amazing it is so I want
to look cute for that picture then I
have to go right to the cellar and do a
central taping that they don't provide
hair and makeup for so I got to do that
and I have to and then I have to make
sure there's just so many things that
I'm juggling that I just eat so I don't
have to think about them I mean no one
else is gonna say I'm gonna say I think
you should get back on the booze I know
and you know sometimes just go just lean
into that have a drink take the edge off
you know I think I could and I think I
will I just think all of my sober
will be very disappointed in me
and how sad were they for you know it's
it's no no I was never in I never really
had a problem big enough so my thing was
just I just stopped it was it wasn't a
bit I didn't have a drinking problem I
just happened to not drink for 12 years
yeah it sounds like more of an issue but
then it is and I drink a little bit now
but not much I think I might give up
again just to lose weight right I think
that what helped you in the first place
no I stopped eating off to six we go
guys the show's over
ah Jimmy Carr thank you so much for
being here you're so fun and exhausting
and uh Matthew Brassard thank you for
being Nancy's name yeah I knew it I was
gonna say going from Scooby Doo
[Music]
you